[Musique]
oh
le corail c'est vraiment la victime
parfaite réchauffement planétaire
quand la température de l'eau monde ne
peut pas s'échapper un degré celsius
c'est ce qui peut faire la différence
entre la vie et la mort la grande
barrière de corail a vraiment souffert
dans les dernières années une vague de
blanchiment 2016 et en 2017 et les
scientifiques ont créé une autre cette
année
donc nous on s'en va plonger avec les
équipes sur le terrain pour voir dans
quel état se trouve aujourd'hui
on parle de 15 dans nord-est de
l'australie et on sera à une heure au
large de la côte est c'est là où l'on
tombe sur la grande barrière récifs
coralliens plus gros clip ali qui
emploie 64 mille personnes nos jeans et
humble à sept-îles qui est d'origine
norvégienne mais qui est tellement
passionné par la préservation des
milieux marins qui elle a déménagé en
australie il ya quatre ans pour
s'occuper des coraux
[Musique]
on vous emmène d'abord dans un endroit
où corail est en très bonne santé
on voit ce coloris et des centaines de
sortes de poissons différentes des
tortues des requins même mais quand on
nage un peu plus loin c'est contraire
ils ceux ci parce que le corail a
blanchi le kids and blue jean yves hinse
est innocent et aux fruits rouges sommes
précipités dehors du basket
universitaire au sort d'un homme mort
atroce sur les 2300 km la grande
barrière
les scientifiques estiment qu'ils en ont
la moitié qui a endommagé depuis cinq
ans mais pourquoi est ce que le
réchauffement climatique affectant les
coraux en gros le corail c'est un animal
mais qui se nourrit grâce aux halles
microscopiques qui se trouve dans son
organisme
le problème c'est que lorsque la
température de l'eau augmente d'à peine
1 ou 2 degrés composition chimique des
algues se dégrade elles deviennent
toxiques et corail n'a pas le choix de
les rejeter
sans ces algues les coraux perdre leurs
sources de nutriments la perdre leur
sucre et peuvent survivre que pendant
quelques semaines
si pour ça qu'ils persistent et tout
pour ça qu'ils blanchissent donc les
high leur donnent leurs couleurs et
leurs nutriments
maintenant même si un corail a blanchi
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est mort il
est faible mais il peut se rétablir si
la température de lourdes et sans messi
après plusieurs semaines l'horaire
chaude l'oeil risque de mourir et pour
qu un récif retrouve son état original
ça peut prendre entre 15 et 20 ans et
c'est là où le travail d'un blog devient
porte et donc leur avenir ou est-ce
qu'elle travaille
rapidement et nous emmène vers ce
qu'elle appelle la garderie coraux c'est
un tout nouveau projet qui a commencé il
ya deux mois
l'idée c'est de prendre un morceau de
corail qui est en bonne santé dans le
récif de le couper en petits morceaux et
l'accrocher à ces structures sous l'eau
sauf peut-être encore un blog d'ailleurs
s'assure qu'aucune arme ne vienne
perturber la croissance des coraux par
quelques mois quand ils sont plus gros
et les relire planté dans le récif à
'vente' et non à suivre mexes à vivre
l'hôtel groslot de croix pour les
projets pilotes et blanc espèrent qu'un
nouveau texte antennes d'autres dans les
prochaines années
mais il doute que ce sera suffisant
charles kennedy il ya d'autres menaces
pour la grande barrière cyclones plus
sévères les risques de déversements avec
les bateaux commerciaux qui navigue dans
le secteur mais la plus grande menace
pour le corail
ça reste le réchauffement de l'eau qui
causent le blanchiment
le problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
que on prévoit d'avoir des
blanchissement à à grande échelle
une fois tous les six ans d'ici 2050
on pourrait commencer à avoir des
planches issement tous les ans tous les
ans et c'est là qu'on va vraiment
commencer à perdre le récif et où les
récifs ne pourra plus se rétablir
[Musique]
dans notre prochain reportage on part de
mes gosses projet de mine de charbon qui
pourrait avoir un impact sur la grande
barrière de corail
[Musique]